[Music]
i know how to vacuum mom and dad summer
i've been doing it for six months but
why would you need to vacuum anything if
time is frozen isn't everything frozen
in time if the molecules of the clothing
are frozen how do you even move them how
does the washer work now that i think
about it how are you even breathing time
frozen oxygen right now it's not my
fault we froze time on a humid day but
the moisture would also free you know
what let's just add five cents for the
paradox of freezing time and move on
shall we you have dropped so many balls
man i mean probably just two although
with the radiation rick has probably
exposed morty to with all the dimension
hopping could be more i suppose put a
shirt on your dumb dad and let's get
this dumb universe rolling but how did
morty get jerry's arms through the
sleeves sleeves just don't magically
form around the arms when you throw a
shirt on no matter how many times you
pray for it when we pulled up i could
have sworn the house was completely
trashed yeah well everyone in the family
knows that rick can do incredible things
so why don't you immediately think rick
must have stopped time and fixed the
house before we walked in i'm just gonna
put it on the floor and uh kick it on
over to you or you could toss jerry the
money so it doesn't look quite as
awkward i know jerry is supposed to be
dumb but beth isn't and she's a doctor
there's no way she's not checking four
heads for temps or at the very least
asking questions about this odd behavior
whatever this is also convenient machine
that can let you know if there's been a
split in time on the off chance you
freeze time long enough for this to be a
possibility is convenient the two of you
made us uncertain what are you talking
about
exactly what does that mean uncertainty
is a pretty broad spectrum for instance
if morty was uncertain about a math
equation or if summer was uncertain
about what clothes she should wear for
that day would that cause a time rift i
get the rick as an ass when it comes to
explaining things but if this issue of
uncertainty is really that important
then maybe you should try a little
harder at least have a sheet with rules
on it cold stone creamery is the best
marble slap creamery shaming we we have
to tell the cops you were driving why
would you have to tell the cops anything
or even call the cops do you call the
cops when you run over a skunk or a
squirrel i believe the saying goes if
the car will still steer you're in the
clear and we've got about four hours to
be is what a very specific time frame
you just happened to know for convenient
engine building purposes all right since
this time crystal exists in both
possibilities and since it's impossible
that i didn't nail this vanity it's
definitely my favorite sin
naming your animal hospital animal
hospital do cars not need license plates
in this world but how will people get in
their practice for removing tiny screws
from rusted out holes by using old
credit cards as an impromptu an
ineffective screwdriver how i ask you
nurse please move that snake that's my
nurse indentured nursitude i shot it
before these two hit it with their car
and i followed them when they hauled it
off and how exactly were you able to
follow them were you hunting from your
car look the scent is either convenient
vehicle location or car hunting take
your pick i'm calling my lawyer i hope
for all our sakes you're as bad a
surgeon as i am a hunter
this episode is an all-timer and
remembered mostly rightfully so for the
time rift storyline but it should also
be noted this b story is equally
hilarious and engaging all right
everything resolved everybody nice and
certain about their position in my world
yes i'm not sure i understand why morty
is so let down here just a couple
episodes ago he discovered that morty's
are a figurative shield for all rix i'm
not saying he should be happy that rick
looks down on him but he shouldn't be
surprised by it this time be like
grandpa you mean drunk this is going to
cause the ricks to go out of sync and
then both ricks are going to take that
as a sign that the other rick is trying
to kill him but earlier morty said
something different from the other morty
and then he said wait who said that so
wouldn't they have heard the other morty
making a wisecrack about rick and
wouldn't rick know that it was the
reason for the sink to go out of whack
hey think about getting in the cupboards
but don't really but rick understands
that all of the ricks would be saying
this right the show has made rick really
dumb over the last 30 seconds for the
sake of moving the plot along so for
that away we go beth pushes jerry with
bloody gloves but there's no blood
transfer to his clothing and trust me
that stuff transfers i mean so i hear i
will reach into heaven and yank your
screaming deer soul back the deer
survives this well all of me knocked out
all the ricks and you peed in all of
your pants doesn't that mean that we're
all synchronized i mean no i haven't
seen a timeline reverse butterfly effect
this hard since the red green grumphold
episode of the x-files what are you
doing calling myself if leaving your
other selves a voicemail was an option
this entire time isn't that a pretty
easy immediate check before going full
interdimensional shooting gallery how
long exactly do we have to wear these
things they're really embarrassing oh i
see rick is an anti-massacre can we talk
about rick's cord maintenance for a bit
he's got four plugs coming up from
behind the work counter and he chooses
to plug three of them towards the top of
the first strip and one of them on the
upper strip and the one coming down from
the ceiling plugs into the lower end of
the top strip what is this nonsense you
have a cord from below plugged in as
your highest cord you cord jumbling
chaos monster these men are from the
servine institute of elk moose deer and
stag they can take this deer to a
helicopter and fly it to the country's
top deer surgeon getting outsmarted by
jerry you know what they do to third
dimensional life forms in time prison
same thing they do in every other prison
only forever so three hots in a cot
medical care tobacco-based currency oh
you're making a prison rape joke aren't
you the last time we sent a prison rape
joke it was in puss in boots so you
might want to think about the company
you keep r m i'm really uncertain about
everything are you though certainly if
the uncertainty is a concerted plan
you're actually certain of your
uncertainty which would in turn create
certain certainty right come on let's
help grandpa yes
i'm 100 not sure about anything at the
war with grandpa hand me that flat head
screwdriver actually
so the decision over which screwdriver
rick should you split off the timelines
again if something that minor would do
it then there should have already been
hundreds of these after rick was trying
to figure out which rick he needed to
kill there is no helicopter
and there is no cervin institute clever
ploy and all but how did jerry get all
the emblems made so quickly to pull this
off and where did the uniforms the cold
stone creamery workers are wearing come
from so the cats float but morty falls
is gravity itself also uncertain
well i guess they can touch jerry and
beth now without any consequences but
how would they know that rick didn't let
them know how long they would have to
wait when they unfroze everything are
you going as motorcycles with green
headlights instead of normal ones i'm
not sure which i want to send more that
jerry would have this type 15 ready to
go right off the top of his head or that
beth who famously eye rolls just about
everything jerry does would be laughing
this hard at it in fact i'm so uncertain
there's no two cents
[Music]
we got some business to attend to a few
light minutes south of here oh you still
use south in space oh jesus jerry what
the hell are you doing here being
excellent at tv sends for one thing also
i'm done with shows pretending like
people have zero spatial awareness even
if you don't have the hyper vigilance
gene where you're always checking your
surroundings one of your five senses is
going to clue you into the fact that
someone's sitting just outside your
peripheral vision and since we're
talking jerry i'm gonna go with smell
you can park in a handicapped spot morty
anything with less than eight limbs is
considered disabled here of course no
one knows where to park because they
apparently don't even mark the spaces
also not having some sort of hover
vehicle parking is just inefficient
planning there should be roof parking
with boxed areas for vertical takeoff
vehicles that don't need all the extra
space to drive around the ferproc design
committee sucks also also looks like
you've got gliz cut over here and then
puisiza two doors down and that's more
poor strip mall planning to have two
pizza places that close to each other
and honestly it might be three because i
could be convinced a place called dumpy
stump sells pizza as well this works
help me
what the hell i know right even though
we know there are multiple versions of
all our characters i'm counting at least
25 jerry's in here is the show
suggesting that a couple dozen ricks
need to ditch jerry's at the same time
when we know most ricks aren't gonna
watch jerry around in the first place
and yes i know the asteroid is cross
temporal which is just rick and morty's
for we wanted to make a joke here so
maybe this will make it okay you know
what those guys do in in their fancy
board rooms they take their balls and
they dip them in cocaine and wipe them
all over each other rick is a liar eight
balling is a myth and he should know
that those pictures of me were clearly
fakes including a period in your hashtag
also when your vocation is life
extermination i'm guessing you're going
to just go ahead and leave the geo
tracker feature off of the business card
for exactly the reasons the show later
confirms yeah sure i mean if you spend
all day shuffling words around you can
make anything sound bad my theory for
when i'm trying to force us in on a show
that probably isn't really a sin but
damn the joke would be so funny and meta
somehow makes it into this episode here
check this out
this all full life simulation game is
exactly the kind of thing that makes
rick and morty such a pleasure and
treats the concept with enough respect
to give it all the time it needs to be
fully felt while at the same time not
letting the joke get stale take your sin
off rick and roy parsons i mean morty
not a single member of this entire crowd
is cheering during this spectacular play
also none of them have faces and most
are clearly copies of other people in
the stands they literally control seed
these four in the front rolling control
veed them to the next row over i'd get
it if this were a cheaply animated tv
show but this is a high-tech game that
simulates an entire life so convincingly
that it becomes your reality hey you
sold a gun to a guy that kills people
yelling this in a public place yeah
that's the difference between you and me
morty i never go back to the carpet
store all right since rick is taking a
turn now we have to talk more about this
game because how can he have awareness
of both the world around him and the
living simulation if it's fully
encompassing also is this game only for
humans the character is human and that
helmet wouldn't fit 90 of the other
clients at this discount dave and
busters there's no way that this would
be profitable and finally if the game
simulates a 55-year life how is it also
showing the player's decisions in real
time on the screen wouldn't that mean it
would take 55 actual years to play who
wants to come watch midnight run with
director's commentary on
martin brest has never recorded a
commentary for midnight run that's a sin
for the show getting its facts wrong a
sin for the collector's edition blue ray
for not making it happen and a sin for
the universe getting me all horned up
for something that doesn't even exist in
my world don't encage him breast play if
you can't finish the job damn it k
michael must either have precognition or
the ability to see through solid objects
neither of which is mentioned or
explained so
sin how is this big guy unaware that a
hole was cut in the floor right beside
him and his co-worker was taken out does
peripheral vision not even exist for
these creatures with 72.4 percent of
their head being eyes oh man
what have i done crashed into a heavily
guarded fortress that apparently didn't
have a single bit of exterior spacecraft
deterrent i guess portal transport that
somehow knows exactly where to bisect
this chesticle mantis threat for reasons
ex machina we can't get him out of here
he's gaseous he's not gonna make it
through a portal morty oh sure now the
portal has rules open fire oh i see my
mistake now i did some fake research and
apparently the company that makes the
portal gun is literally titled
ex-machina inc it's like the whole
purpose of this gun apparently fair
enough i'll take back all the portal
sins we've ever done and by take back i
obviously mean double also this room
fills up with water even though there's
a giant hole in the wall where morty
drove the ship through a few minutes ago
rick yeah yeah these guards apparently
attended the promethean nebula school of
just standing around and not shooting
your guns even though you're about to
die or you know if you still have that
gun k michael dropped we could finish
the job and go home you do understand
i'm telepathic right not sure why this
matters since rick is saying everything
out loud and not with his mind it's how
things should be it's how they could be
i could not agree more this psychedelic
unity musical number that is like the dr
strange's open your eye scene but less
about the astral projection and more
about butts goes on for some time we now
interrupt this masturbatory reference to
a different episode with some news
position news position a tv crutch so
useful even rick and morty can't help
but do it sorry rick the reward on your
head is too high higher than access to a
creature that's gold seems like he could
have dished out some raisin bran gotten
a few bars out of the deal and let rick
and morty be on their way how are cogs
that big fitting through mouth holes
that small gear troopers are apparently
this world's version of stormtroopers
put these guys on a milk carton cause
they've been missing this whole time i
can't figure out where the main pot
starts and where the jerry potts begin
but if those three coins in front of our
jerry is all he has left then he
shouldn't fold even with ace high these
pod odds are way too good to not play
and i don't expect jerry to know that
but i just can't let that kind of bad
poker go unsend i'm now way more curious
about how gear people sex works than i'm
comfortable with i've been grinding my
gears trying to figure it out so to
speak i'm gonna find some fuel and take
a big fat morty that's my new word for
because of today's events explaining
your jokes which is hilarious because we
also do it which also makes it meta and
honestly the more we explain it the more
meta it gets get it telepathic being
that rube goldberg the destruction of an
entire police force to escape somehow
didn't see this coming interesting
somehow didn't see this coming it's also
the title of my why would all the ricks
and mortys be picking up their jerry's
at the exact same time and so help me if
it's just so we can set up a hilarious
taking home the wrong jerry joke i'm
gonna laugh my ass off but also still
add the sin
experience
excitement distress beacon oh yeah baby
you're excited about that i'm confused
as to how at this point morty is
surprised by anything that rick says or
does the first rule of space travel kids
is always check out distressed beacons
oof rick is using an outdated space
travel rule book the most important rule
of space travel is to wear your seatbelt
seems like something terrible happened
here really where'd you get that idea
summer was it the ship in disarray no
signs of life or maybe the [ __ ]
distress beacon that brought you here
summer makes worse observations than
forest whitaker and species oh yeah if
you find a room full of eggs don't shy
away from it give one of them a shake so
does this mean that xenomorphs exist in
this universe which would also mean the
regular space exploration is something
that exists on earth and rick shouldn't
be getting away with as much as he does
also does no one find it weird that when
they watch ghostbusters or gorillas in
the mist that the lead actress looks
straight up like ellen ripley
oh hey you're alive thank god false
optimism then how do you know it didn't
get on the ship with you those two
ding-dongs seem pretty calm about the
whole thing which poses the question why
did they wait till now to attack the
rest of the crew even if unity was
hoping someone would show up from the
distress signal they could also take
over that still doesn't explain why
these two didn't attack after the beacon
was transmitted
why screech make the attack incredibly
obvious there's got to be a better way
for a brilliant entity to expertly and
covertly convert everyone into well
everyone whoever grows here must love to
be saturated in water but only in one
tiny place on the whole lawn i'm trying
to find our weed whacker jerry's dumb
you know that i know that but i can't
help but sin that he's looking for a
long lawn tool on a shelf where no one
would ever store a weed whacker your
father put a hatch in my garage which
means now you have even more storage
space under the garage and probably
added ten to twenty thousand dollars to
the value of the house jerry never sees
the glass half full he's toe up from the
flow up this is season two and they
still haven't managed to move this plug
down here to one of the obvious three
open ports i hate you all world peace
achieved nice little weird to publish a
paper about it for yourself i think at
this point we can agree that rick would
be the employee of the month that tv
sends when we met i was a young hive
mind people who talk to you while
walking away i suppose a peaceful utopia
needs a police force for something mount
rushmore this quickly show really puts
the rush into rushmore huh well this
explains the six thousand dollar
electric bill wait what was the previous
explanation that sounds far more
exciting than this jerry beth bickering
b story
wake up people you have to fight it
you're under the spell of an evil
monster i can hear you every four years
in the united states of america wake up
you have to have some individuality left
in there pep talks around the writing
table during cinemas and staff meetings
this woman was a drug addict on the
verge of suicide now she's a marine
biologist which isn't impressive when
you consider that everyone on the planet
is also a marine biologist thanks to the
hive mind i have transformed life here
into a paradise prostitutes are now
scientists insinuating that sex workers
cannot also be scientists in a perfect
world
are they all the same organism is the
mind telling them to puke unity can read
their minds improve them with education
link everyone together and relieve her
drug binge through individuals how does
this even work i can let go can you also
teleport people because in exactly four
seconds the city is destroyed in all the
people are somehow way over here
rick can hear this from far away inside
a building and with loud techno music
playing and i'll be damned if that
ripple nipple bitch's race is superior
those are some very impressive conical
nipples attached to that [ __ ] nibbles
that were clearly not present beneath
that shirt just a moment ago hey these
two freaks have no race speaking of
freaks what's going on with this crowd
of totally still people back here are
they unity controlled just standing by
all hands on hips angry looking are they
rioters frozen in terror or is this lazy
animation you want to go upstairs and
cut carrots and watch a lifetime
original above
alien dungeon surprisingly mommy may i
please have an alien dungeon proved to
be a very uplifting piece of filmmaking
especially for a lifetime movie i once
saw him briefly forget the word for
humans this sets up a joke later in the
episode but it's really not that big of
a deal to forget a word every now and
again our minds calculate thousands of
decisions a day so what if we forget a
word like right now i'm having trouble
remembering the word for that thing
that's like soft but then it gets hard
you know you put it in holes and cracks
it's really good in places that are wet
oh yeah yeah [ __ ] you and unity are like
like leggings and mid-calf boots you
think you're great together but you're
just bringing out the worst in each
other that's fashionist if blim blam
could rip the chains off this whole time
then why was he still locked up i'd
laugh but i'm biologically incapable but
somehow capable of communicating clear
words in dynamically expressive versions
of
just not able to ha ha is there a slow
setting
best door ever sarcastic aliens not
named health unity community
rick forgive me for doing this in notes
breaking up with someone through a
letter also reading no more alien
prisoners but aliens suspended in some
sort of liquid chamber are okay is
anyone going to address these
[Music]
emotionally relevant songs sincerely
plays at the end of a rick and morty
episode while also making fun of
emotionally relevant songs that play at
the end of tv shows cliche i wanted to
thank you for letting me live here all
this time so i'm treating the family to
a vacation pro tip a vacation is not a
treat if it's thrown on you at the last
minute people have to take off work or
school or find pet sitters last minute
vacations are [ __ ] anxiety-filled
balls of stress there is nothing fun
about them well i don't like your
unemployed jeans and my grandchildren
jerry but life is made of little
concessions
i guess this is the tv sins takes off a
sin from rick and morty because it's
hilarious cliche while has alien
parasite heads batter wall has no alien
parasite heads batter there's no such
thing as an uncle steve that is an alien
parasite and even though everyone else
will immediately turn back into the
parasite when shot uncle steve decided
to wait a few seconds for dramatic
effect how thoughtful i get they need to
address this problem but i don't
understand why rick had to throw the
parasite on the table that's perfectly
good breakfast casserole you just ruined
why would you do that rick why get off
the high road summer we all got pink eye
because you won't stop texting on the
toilet joe insinuates that there is a
single human being on the planet who
doesn't use their phone while busting
grumpies the pink eye is worth it and we
all know it so it's actually rick that
needs to get off his high horse or pie
road or whatever high he's on in this
opening credits cut scene mr booby
butthole holds his nose while jumping
into the portal but we all remember when
this originally happened pb had
experienced portals many times before
and would know this was unnecessary look
i've been a fan of the pups b-hole since
season one episode one i know these
things having a slumber party style
pillow fight in your day clothes maybe
you got the first one in time rin
can't afford to chance it but rick
apparently could afford to wait until
now to barricade the house instead of as
soon as he realized these things had
potentially infested the house also
considering how many we find out there
are what are the chances none of them
had already ventured out of the house
i'm guessing slim to poopy butthole just
pee your pants i did it the minute we
got stuck then are you wearing a diaper
summer because those pants are as white
as christmas and i see no sign of pee
not that i want to but i've got a job to
do here people it's me cousin nikki i'm
walking here i mean i'm not i'm
crouching the elevator shaft but hey i'm
walking here
still a better dustin hoffman impression
than the one in sphere also deus ex
nicona nikki was the reason we found
that old nazi submarine did that not
even happen well you know this episode
is really just a clever excuse to do
more interdimensional cable type
cutaways which is strange because they
would do a literal sequel to that
episode just four episodes after this
one i guess what i'm saying is it's
pretty obvious that this episode is just
another excuse to make up wild scenarios
with no canonical consequence and as
someone who needs canonical consequence
to do their job correctly i find this
annoying
and deus ex borah gardner is ex machina
a requirement of adding new memories
no don't flash back thing i say watching
this is us or arrow or the walking dead
or pretty much every single show on
television somehow makes its way into
the script marmalade is served and
apparently self-replenishing as well
considering he just poured out half of
that jar on jerry and now it's almost
full again look there's only supposed to
be six this number gimmick is fun and
all but i have some questions if they
can multiply this quickly why didn't
uncle steve already have several new
friends at the start before rick got
there how are subsequent parasites able
to control everyone's mind but uncle
steve couldn't control ricks and finally
a raptor can the parasite specifically
change the part of the memory that knows
that even though raptor photographers
are a thing they shoot solely on digital
i'm having a blast here for sure but i'm
also having a hard time grasping how any
of this works here rick use me oh thanks
pencil vester let's just think about a
sentient pencil who also functions as a
working pencil for a second because it's
[ __ ] terrifying what happens when the
lead starts diminishing what happens
when it has to be sharpened
photos hard evidence and that should be
the end of it this show will quickly
shift from this with some sleight of
hand but all they have to do is pull out
an old photo album or some family
vacation videos and this thing is over i
will admit it's suspicious that summer's
only friend is a magic ballerina lamb
that we've never seen i find it
suspicious that creature that
self-identifies as frankenstein use the
term only friend when summer just said
her phone was filled with pictures of
her friends from school nipple x's rick
that is my daughter says the guy who
just stated that except for beth and
jerry all bets are off shut up hamurai
shut up amish cyborg what is this 90's
conan
rick as per usual would be the goat at
tv sins this living room has never been
this big also i'm pretty sure there are
at least seven that's racist in here so
i'll throw those in as well also also
i'm guessing every last one of these
characters has its own fan wiki page and
what i'm saying is we should all find
better ways to spend our time fandom
ruins us all
i'm really curious about the multiplying
process of this species it appears they
can just appear immediately once they're
transposed into a memory but how do they
appear in the memory in the first place
doesn't appear they need another
parasite's memory to do that because
once steve was killed the next parasite
cousin nicki appeared in mr poopy
butthole's memory and we eventually find
out mr poopy butthole is a real person
so if they don't need another parasite's
memory then why wouldn't they all just
appear immediately this is the
equivalent of the ghost that can kill
you right away instead choosing to show
you how it has the ability to move
chairs around and we'll be right back
after these messages i don't hate a lot
about rick and morty but the blatant
fourth wall breaks make me angry
probably because when you destroy that
wall so casually and so completely you
destroy a show's ability for any part of
the narrative to even matter ever and i
like things that occasionally matter and
we can play nintendo games nintendo give
me free stuff i'm guessing they just did
since that nintendo ds was not in your
hand you'd set them all down in the
kitchen so you could grab the cash to go
buy more what is going on with morty in
this picture looks like mr bill's ugly
cousin i get that the animators probably
don't pay as much attention to the
background but you've animated this
character many times over and everyone
else looks like themselves in the
pictures sleepy gary even got a cool hat
in his leaving your pants unbuttoned
maybe we'll see chewbacca
what are we doing i'm guessing not
getting to see chewbacca sleepy gary is
such a tease grass
tastes bad grass actually has a pretty
neutral taste compared to the bitterness
of most plants
so how would you use this washing
machine to actually wash clothes
obviously this memory is fake because do
you know of a single amusement park that
would have this much space between
roller coasters and not use it for
souvenir shops carnival cheat games or
overpriced burger shops what oh was that
bottle recently painted purple and the
paint hasn't dried because black eyes
like that take at least a few minutes to
develop morty give a gun to the lady
that got pregnant with me too early and
constantly makes it our problem this
message about how our flaws or the
things that make us human and connect us
is actually really smart and sweet and
i'd like to take a sin off for rick and
morty actually having some depth and
meaning but the show casually broke the
fourth wall earlier so my hands are tied
my wife shot a long time family friend
funny yeah mr poopy butthole being an
actual being and long time friend make
any sense whatsoever no and you know how
we feel about things that prioritize a
laugh over the sanctity of complete
logical consistency that's right we're
the only ones that get to do it and
that's the way
the sins goes show opens up on earth
getting head
hey golf is easy now and yet despite the
surrounding explosions and cataclysm
still unspeakably boring wearing
sunglasses indoors also why does rick
put his sunglasses on in the living room
only to take them off before he and
morty have even made it outside a place
where the sunglasses may actually be
needed with this show i could totally
buy that they took a detour via some far
away planet with 42 suns on their way
from the living room to the garage but
if that's the case why didn't rick give
morty a pair as well it's not god summer
she's allowed to think it's god if she
wants honey mixing parenting and
politics i mean religion i mean religion
in politics i mean this is how you get
ants summer hi i'm morty's math teacher
i'm also part of the street team
inviting folks to the church downtown so
we can pray together how long ago did mr
potato head in space turn up have they
really had time to organize a street
team dedicated to inviting people to
church if so where are your priorities
people if you can mobilize this quickly
why not help the probable millions that
have been displaced by aforementioned
natural disasters also why is the math
teacher not questioning the fact that
rick morty just flew away in a spaceship
right in front of him how is praying
going to help beth would be schwifty at
tv sins seti norad and every broadcaster
on the planet are attempting to show
this being what humanity's got string
theory world history the human genome
have you tried sending in launch codes
what that's a terrible idea is general
warmonger suggesting they send nuclear
launch codes to an obviously superior
alien being with clearly questionable
intent now i'm sure his actual meaning
here was to fire the missiles but that
is not what he said people mr president
what america's got is 70 000 megatons of
kaboom boom i wanted to send the fact
that 70 000 megatons must be a colossal
over exaggeration of how many nuclear
weapons america has after a small amount
of googling it turns out that is the
generally accepted estimate of the size
of our nuclear arsenal and that is a sin
now the sunglasses are back so why did
they take rick's spaceship in the first
place why not just portal gun their way
in like they were clearly going to do in
the first draft of this script also this
begs the question why does rick have a
spaceship at all surely it's easier
safer and quicker to just portal gun
everywhere stay back this watch turns
people into snakes we'll find out later
rick has actually murdered these people
and the snakes are being released from a
contraption to sell the illusion and he
is not punished for it then or now so
the sin as always is kids i mean murder
i mean
give me a ding pharrell newman corgan
and that dream guy they're all dead the
grammy sir there was an earthquake and
all the musicians
all the famous ones they're gone when
was the last time randy
newman was at the grammys or billy
corrigan for that matter get this man
and his grandson on a black hawk to area
51 or and this could be a terrible
inconvenience for everyone i understand
use the portal you double down and
always hit on a soft 16. i think hitting
on soft 16s has landed the church in
plenty enough hot water as it is thank
you very much
in case you confused it with nevada
desert the setting of that awful dave
bautista zombie movie yes i'm gonna send
army of the dead at every and any
opportunity regardless of the size of
the shoehorn required get schwifty what
the hell is that it's our world's best
effort that's what how can that possibly
be true okay every artist at the grammys
was killed but there are plenty of great
artists that have never been nominated
for a grammy what about the kinks the
strokes the spice girls the talking
heads the planet's about to be destroyed
by a literal talking head your saviors
are right there
i like what you got good job
this song works mr president you're
gonna want to see this you'd better come
take a look at this cliche sure he
started picking up on a garbled signal
we're decrypting it now decrypting it
based on what frick wasn't here you
wouldn't even know what these aliens
were called let alone their language 24
hours five planets five songs but in the
end there can only be one planet music
trashy reality tv set in space this show
sounds incredible i can't wait to binge
all 988 seasons
uh it's probably a bad time to mention
it but any astronauts you guys had in
orbit are definitely dead everyone on
earth except orbiting astronauts
survives this
earlier all marty had to do is press the
key and the keyboard automatically
played a funky beat wouldn't this time
be better spent cycling through the
pre-programmed beats instead of trying
to accidentally himself into a tune also
while we're on the topic of the keyboard
shouldn't they find the person that
programmed the keyboard with the winning
beat i'm fairly certain they weren't
invited to the grammys you can put your
faith in nukes if we get through this
general until then i'll put mine in rick
and morty usually i would also be in
favor of anything other than the nuclear
option but after having sent a good few
of these episodes the phrase i put my
faith in rick and morty makes me lean
towards the big red button as a safer
option with the opportunity for far less
damaging fallout we should pack up and
leave town now and go where is it not
clear by the floating heads in the sky
that there's nowhere to just pack up and
head to we hereby send these unwantable
skyward that they might be inhaled by
the many heads this is an entirely
inefficient method of dealing with your
unwantables do you know how many helium
balloons it takes to lift your average
person the internet does it would take
approximately 65 000 liters of helium or
60 000 liters of hydrogen to lift your
average sized human that's over 5 000
regular sized balloons also you'd
probably need to double that if you
wanted to get any sort of altitude for
smiting movie talker hey wait no that's
probably fair please help me you can
reach me if you try please help me
inappropriate joke teller okay now i
just feel attacked morty bird person
morty lands on a planet of bird people
and just happens to be greeted by the
one bird person he knows
what the [ __ ] you can turn into ice my
story begins at the dawn of time in the
far away realm of alpha betrium 23
minute tv show has time for this amount
of ice position okay things are getting
out of hand getting giant head from
space has created cataclysmic natural
disasters around the world the planet
has been teleported to who the fork
knows where to participate in some sort
of intergalactic singing contest with an
80 mortality rate and all of your best
musicians are already dead i repeat
getting out of hand i'm setting the
nuclear option to launch one minute into
earth's performance and you mr president
i hope you like being hit in the face
with a gun wait wait wait why
doesn't the general need the president
to be conscious so that he can authorize
said nuclear option if he doesn't need
the president's codes or authorization
why hasn't he launched them already i
believe i can access the history of
rick's gun and help you get back to him
snooping through the browser history of
someone else's electronic device not
that you'd find anything in mind nope no
sir not mine clean as a whistle
and you guys did you guys see that one
thing on the do you see at the place the
one thing can we can we move on now once
in for the mental image resulting from
reading the band name flesh curtains i
married you because you're the love of
my life going to need a whole lot of
balloons full of an intergalactic skip
just launch the missiles maybe all it
takes to launch nuclear missiles is one
guy at a computer pressing a button but
if that's true i don't want to know
about it and it's no less of a sin after
988 seasons of planet music the
cromulons have decided to declare earth
the final winner and bring our musical
reality show to a conclusion goodbye
oh man now what am i gonna watch ooh
maybe there's a uk version trade secret
mr president particle beam and a
wristwatch
snake holster on the leg but how does he
refill the snakes while he's out and
about
laughing at murder geez i can't believe
we found a version of earth with a ball
fondler's movie franchise even this
early in the series i find it impossible
to believe that morty could be surprised
by much of anything they find
considering all the insane adventures
they've been on to this point also they
choose ball fondlers over french toast i
can't speak to either movie's quality
but i can attest to the fact that ball
fondling is so much better after helping
a french toast or so i've heard allowing
full house to exist in more than one
reality what's wrong is it the quantum
carburetor or something jesus morty you
can't just add a sci-fi word to a car
word and hope it means something over
800 episodes of star trek would beg to
differ wait you can't leave me here to
be fair he can but i'm not sure why he
does if rick can bring morty with him
into the battery i'm not sure why he
couldn't bring summer as well in fact
rick knows that summer would be less of
a buzz kill so if anything why isn't he
leaving morty in the car if rick and the
gang are in a different reality who is
summer texting did we miss them getting
an interdimensional cell phone plan
added onto their interdimensional cable
package either way we're looking at one
sin for the show or one for [ __ ]
cable companies always trying to upsell
you on sh i know that the joke
throughout this episode is that the ship
follows rick's instructions to the
extreme but why would rick program it to
start with murder as its first line of
defense rick's an imaginative guy what
about electrifying the door or i don't
know having the ship move itself away
from the danger where are we rick morty
remember eight seconds ago when you said
go inside what and i said the battery
and then we showed up here and i wasn't
like whoa this is unexpected this is not
what i was expecting morty as is always
the case rick would be excellent at tv
sins i put a spatially tesselated void
inside a modified temporal field until a
planet developed intelligent life by
this point i know the quest for any
semblance of meaning or logic behind the
science and rick and morty is a
fruitlessly frustrating one so to that
end i'm gonna save my sanity and time
and leave this with a very simple and
succinct how the [ __ ] can this possibly
work you have a whole planet sitting
around making your power for you that's
slavery it's society confusing the
inherent flaws that come with any modern
society with the actual [ __ ]
aberration that is slavery it appears we
are being revisited by the alien known
as rick who once gave our world the gift
of google box technology sinful news
position is sinful and all that but how
is this new story already being
broadcasted rick just got there and they
haven't actually seen him in person how
do they know someone else isn't flying
the discount board cube also why does
the newscaster have to explain what
google box technology is the
civilization is literally built to use
this technology who there wouldn't know
what a google box is do they need to
have one of these hooked up to every
household appliance and does that mean
that the appliance only works while the
stomping is in progress why don't they
have a way of storing the energy they
generate where the [ __ ] are these cables
going why are they a different color why
is fluval gorks morty gotta flip them
off i told them it means peace among
worlds how hilarious is that as
hilarious as this prank is what's the
point it doesn't mean to these aliens
because they have no context for the
gesture's original meaning and it's not
like anyone is going to come visit the
universe held inside rick's ship battery
just to appreciate this flipping off of
an entire civilization consequence free
i bet there are plenty of [ __ ] that
would pay good money to do that
including me either way someone deserves
a sin i would love to see it [ __ ] you
who did you say to me
you
you told me it means much obliged how is
much obliged a suitable response to rick
wanting to see this genius invention
shouldn't he have said something like
happy to oblige unless much obliged
actually means happy to oblige to these
people in which case [ __ ] you would it
be possible for us to get some kind of
tour of your miniverse from the inside
why bother with a tour just destroy the
damn thing and make up some bs about why
they're forbidden to create this
technology again he is a literal god to
them this isn't a [ __ ] chocolate
factory i don't have time this comment
doesn't necessarily mean that the
wonkaverse exists in this entirely
unique and self-contained universe but
it does mean the chocolate exists and as
comforting as it is to discover that
chocolate appears to be a multiversal
constant it really doesn't make a damn
bit of sense so yes i'm sending
chocolate all right let's go
how did zerp flirterberg know that rick
would know to hold on to him and morty
for this to work and how [ __ ] quick
are rick's reactions there was zero
warning for this sudden transportation
what are you doing telling this guy that
his many verse is unethical did do you
not see the hypocrisy here the only
thing i see is an implausible belief on
morty's behalf that rick isn't this
disingenuous and awful as a human being
hypocrisy indeed looked in a mirror
lately morty incoming got a device
yet no one moves back crank it i told
them this means peace among worlds but
the gestures lip-slop is making actually
is the sign for peace in our universe at
least so does that mean this two-finger
gesture independently evolved to have
the opposite meaning in this microverse
culture thus allowing him to comically
assign it the inverse meaning in this
mini-verse which has actually meant its
reversion back to the original meaning
as we know in our universe are they not
really aliens no they're just a couple
of crazy wacky scientists you know i
hate to be the well actually guy
who am i kidding of course i don't
anyways from this perspective they're
all the very definition of aliens
pterodactyl
[ __ ] the only reason this exclamation
should have scared zlapp vanderflange is
if he's aware of what a pterodactyl is
which means this place also evolved
dinosaurs this would be a bizarre
mathematical impossibility even if it
were just another planet this is another
planet an entirely different universe i
guess the multiverse must really [ __ ]
love dinosaurs honestly you can't blame
them don't flatter yourself there's
always triple a you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i've heard the quantum battery add-on to
the triple-a plan is priced very
reasonably what are we going to do now
question from the writers room when
struggling with this very weak b story
somehow make their way into the episode
we are now three layers of distinct
universe deep and the most variety this
evolutionary gene pool could muster is a
third eye on a deer this is still a
[ __ ] deer i don't know whether to
send the fact that this deer would have
definitely heard this timber-based
jaeger situation coming from a mile away
and would have long since bolted or the
fact that this [ __ ] tries to lunge
for it instead of using this [ __ ]
boulder launcher to kill it both it is i
hope your god is as big a dick as you my
god's the biggest dick that's never
existed blasphemy
[Music]
rick has formed for using snakes in this
way so i'm prepared to reluctantly buy
this element of his armory however the
cream of this carefully crafted pie of
[ __ ] is that with this limited
amount of storage space zulu von stick
here chose to keep a [ __ ] eagle just
in case of this very eventuality and it
[ __ ] worked oh wow okay
that is pretty gay using the word gay as
an insult i masturbated to an extra
curvy piece of driftwood the other day
xylophiles oh hey guys i just finished
cooking us a feast the [ __ ] is there a
kitchen in this lab for also who would
want to live in a universe where one pan
of beige constitutes a feast
genocide a long time ago i implanted you
with the subdermal chip that could call
upon dormant nanobots in your
bloodstream to restructure your anatomy
and turn you into a car turning your
grandson into a turbo teen without
explicit consent
rick's eyes survive this
um guys
what happens if the hood is locked ew
what the hell jesus there's flies in my
ice cream flice cream nice to see
everyone's just sitting here patiently
with their two eggs two sausages pancake
and i'm gonna say rice
grits cottage cheese my point is why is
no one eating yet rick and morty episode
sub standard breakfast operating
procedure cliche this time it's the case
of the inappropriate bowl of cereal
everyone knows that you eat cereal while
the main breakfast is cooking and if
that [ __ ] has been sitting there in a
puddle of milk getting soggier by the
second i will lose my damn mind and
don't think it gets a pass if this
morning malady is at the pre-milked part
of its journey this bowl is filled to
capacity with cereal how does morty
expect to be able to add any milk to
this without some serious cereal seepage
what is up with this balloon game that
jerry's playing first i thought he was
popping just the blue balloons but then
he pops a red one and then i wondered
why there's no score listed so what's
the point but then i realized their apps
were just pop fake bubble wrap like this
so now the sins for app culture and
bleeding my bank account dry 99 cents at
a time sorry i wasn't paying attention
to a conversation about vampires in
fairness to jerry vampires are one of
the least interesting conversation
topics to happen around this breakfast
table so not sure why everyone's so
worked up about it also making me use
the phrase in fairness to jerry we tried
a couple's therapist that's earth
therapy you might as well ask a horse to
fix a merry-go-round it may not be
perfect and may take a lot of work but
strangely enough earth therapy is the
only therapy most people on earth have
access to and if i have to throw sin on
one of the funniest shows of all time
just to remind you that therapy is
indeed amazing ding away also does he
mean an actual horse or one of the
horses on the merry-go-round itself i
suppose one is as ridiculous as the
other but both prove the point he's
trying to make but this is an oddly
specific example of futility and
sometimes i just want to know where this
comes from i'm gonna go make some wooden
stakes good luck summer there's one
thing i know about rick and morty it's
they don't really specialize in having
steaks i booked you for a two-day
intensive at nuptia 4 the galaxy's most
successful couples counseling institute
this place has a 100 success rate of
fixing marriages and is open to the
entire galaxy but somehow rick was able
to book them in with zero notice i can't
even book a damn haircut with that sort
of notice my shoe fits up your ass you
wish
[Laughter]
take that back you do not think that
about me joe doesn't clearly explain
that she's not really angry about the
whole killer insect thing it was
actually the four boobs who wants to
carry around two more of those nuisances
character closes a door and is scared by
a younger [ __ ] clone of their
grandfather standing behind it cliche oh
my god toby matthews boy crazy summer is
my least favorite summer but strangely
enough also my most favorite summer the
next step is to watch your mythologues
interact together and uh big surprise
it's never pretty is the battle between
the physical manifestations of your
deepest and most uncensored thoughts
about your significant other really the
sort of thing that should be aired in
front of complete strangers in what way
is that therapeutic for anybody
we can work together
smearing your arm oil on your worm
husband honestly guys have you ever
tried to send this show modesty hands
and i guess it's time for me to get back
inside the old timer i'll let one of our
honorary tv sense team members take this
one um phrasing where are the smith
mythologues sending someone in to check
instead of just watching back the
surveillance footage you do have
surveillance footage in your fancy
futuristic marriage monster prisons
right also this works seriously was the
wall matching color of this giant
[ __ ] glute ball really enough to hide
it i mean it's clearly spilling over
these steps what the heck did glick
glacfufeem think this thing was is
anybody listening can anyone understand
stop looking at me like that and
actually help me rhyming understand with
help me surely race this advanced has
the ability to present these murderous
marital monstrosities as harmless
holograms they'd still be able to
observe how they interact without the
risk of all this maiming then again i
suppose that means this b-plot would
actually end up being about the
complexities of dealing with long-term
relationships and then we'd be in danger
of actually learning something
bad noise continue the smashing and
slicing also if they absolutely have to
take a physical form which they don't
why would they send this guy all on his
own and leave the door wide [ __ ] open
if you know that this is the sort of
havoc and destruction they could cause
and this place has a 100 success rate my
trip advisor review shall say otherwise
what the hell kind of relationship do
you have i mean you just screamed
they're codependent
so are you being rhetorical here has
your universally lauded marriage
counseling service never dealt with
codependency earlier these creatures
called our planet earth as if they
didn't know how to pronounce earth but
the entire map is in english make up
your mind ridiculous animated comedy
show if you can find one too we should
be safe for hours maybe days there is so
much room in this panel for both of them
that even jack and rose are scoffing at
jerry right now get outside read a book
this episode says tiny rick more than
the pickle rick episode says pickle rick
i feel like the writers may be
overcompensating for something here hmm
tiny
pickle
give me a second i'm gonna figure it out
why was knight raider called knight
rider the car's name was kit nobody rode
michael knight rick would be excellent
at a knight rider episode of tv sims why
was knight raider called knight rider
the car's name was kit nobody rode
michael knight see get your [ __ ]
together get it all together and put it
in a backpack all your sh this gets it
together for some
no nobody's doing that around 41 percent
of people are doing that you want jerry
i don't even want jerry that's jerry's
stacking your cups this eye is just
asking for some [ __ ] kid to
accidentally knock them over as a
distraction to put some special
ingredient in the punch bowl shorter cup
stacks are the road to true sobriety
friends let me out let me out
this is not a dance this sin goes out to
the rick and morty fan who rocked this
dance at his local club thinking
everyone would think it was hilarious
for getting the rick and morty uber fans
are a much smaller subset of humanity
than you might think and was mocked and
embarrassed and could never show his
face again in allen's anticipation
station and it's me this sid goes out to
me you're a great student the fact that
you're an 80 year old man and a clone
body never bothered me but it really
should why is everyone even aware of
this let alone okay with it and how has
rick managed to prove himself as a great
student he's only been there since this
morning and i don't think he's even been
in any classes and if he has
why he's meant to be hunting [ __ ]
vampires how can one sentence contain so
much sin summer smith is a [ __ ]
psycho nerd and she just got me kicked
out of school not owning your sh i'm
here to save you or my name isn't jerry
smith
yes jerry smith
yeah no show has a right to be this
funny and genuinely insightful at the
same time it's just not fair to the
other shows and yes that means i'm
giving this show a sin because other
shows can't match it but don't look at
me that way you knew which channel you
clicked on honey i like to believe that
hugh jackman's character from the
prestige survived found some youth juice
and eventually became his character in
reminiscence and that this machine is
the twisted result of a merger of both
of his infamous inventions i have
nothing to base this on but now that
i've shared this with you don't act like
you don't want it to be true as well
unless this clock is broken and there's
no reason to assume it is the school
dance was taking place at two in the
afternoon when they should all no i
don't know be in classes also this
calendar has at most 20 squares in total
of course this all could be taking place
in an alternate reality where the months
only have 20 days and school dances
regularly take place at 2pm but i'm not
prepared to believe in a universe where
such madness is possible now back to the
80 year old in the clone body of his
teenage self attempting to murder his
original older self what are you gonna
do i'm tiny rick i'm the coolest kid in
your school you have been expelled sir
your threats are hollow rick comes out
of the vat and marty says rick while
summer says pants and while i don't
blame summer for her cultural norm views
on nude body boundaries regarding
grandparents i will say it's weird that
you chose this moment to be all of a
sudden so grossed out when his tiny rick
has been in clear view the whole episode
why go through all of the effort of
strategically covering the rick if
you're just gonna blur it anyway now is
there a set budget of blurs per episode
mass sanchezide just so you're prepared
there's a bunch of dead me's in the
garage speaking of multiple me's what
the [ __ ] is going to happen to the
assorted cast of into the jerry verse
back here i know nobody behind rick and
morty is interested in answering those
sort of questions but damn it i want my
loose ends tied up hey phrasing
don't worry about jerry jesus that door
opened hella fast how many broken noses
have these doors caused and how many
people have been sent to the hospital
while in this hospital it'll stain if it
gets on your clothes and it'll send you
into a murderous rage if it gets in your
eyes or mouth seems like this hospital
would be doing everything it could to
make sure jerry couldn't projectile
vomit that stuff on anybody or at the
very least make sure anyone nearby was
protected from him hello i'm dr glib
glock if jerry is affected by the same
mutant bacteria why didn't he get sent
into a murderous rage and maybe rick did
something to jerry where he didn't have
to kill him but why didn't he do the
same for the doctor is it because
hilarity what are you doing a sequel i
don't understand yeah me neither we
pretty much nailed it the first time
acknowledging your premise is likely not
going to be very good so you can lower
people's expectations and people can
forget about the usual high quality of
your work cliche ow that l is fully up
in there and i hope for her sake these
wooden letters have been sandpapered
smooth splinters in your sensitive bits
can ruin a good wood in the ass moment
you know also you're calling this one
interdimensional cable 2 even though the
first one was called rixty minutes you
got some rambo 3 in my rick and morty
guys not cool man versus car so every
single one of these shows will be random
and stupid in the hope of generating
roughly the same number of laughs as the
last time they did this but they went
with randomer and stupider for this one
i hope that when you told your friends
about rick and morty this wasn't the
first episode you showed them i'm
looking through your eye holes yes look
through my eye holes my boner is
confused also we're about to find out
that these eye holes are a breakfast
cereal
puts their cereal on their faces and has
weird foreplay like this or is this the
species where eye holes come from this
is an improvisational pretzel you're
guiding me through
is that rope made of metal or is the
skylight glass really thin how did that
break the glass i'm the only one that's
allowed to have eye holes right after
this rick will say that this guy
actually beats you up if you possess eye
holes so i have a lot of questions first
if the company making eye holes is
advertising this why would they hire
this guy as their mascot you know the
one who beats the out of you for eating
them second how does the ihome man know
that you have isles i mean this guy came
in a helicopter which had to have been
in flight before this couple even
revealed their eye holes third and more
importantly you can buy these at ikea
and why does this place have stores
earth has is it a comment on their
ubiquity shrimply pebbles life can be
saved if we replace his heart with your
human penis after the scenario was
revealed a writer for house woke up in a
cold sweat and yelled why didn't we
think of that their entire culture is
built around their penises man i don't
know how i got verna her song for this
episode and to say this but i'll remove
a sin just because listening to him talk
matter of factly about jokes is
hilarious but also while i'm listening
to something hilarious look at those fly
wings how are they on the outside of the
lab jacket until shrimpy pibbles that
when the galaxy king calling jerry smith
from earth didn't flinch he's right
there jer pretty sure he just told him
beth and summer are cruising their
smartphones from an intergalactic
hospital and i'm wondering how any of
that works does the alien hospital have
wi-fi that connects to different planet
technology are there satellites that
transmit all the way back to earth while
summer texts how did i get here it's
that lady with a [ __ ] on her face like
war from star trek that was getting
coffee how did she get there it is it's
the same woman infinite channels
infinite possibilities but sure why not
have something happen to her on tv
immediately after morty noticed her we
need one gen michael vincent to quadrant
c we need two jan michael vinsons to
quadrane seems the main problem this
world is having is that there are only
eight jan michael vincent's in 16
quadrants the jan michael vinson factory
wouldn't send two jan michael vinsons to
one quadrant i'm clearly sending the
fake movie and not rick and morty here
but where else am i going to put this in
this show where somebody steals stuff
must be a sham because that camera
didn't follow steely through the door it
panned over through this huge opening on
the left side of this guy's office so
either this is a studio or steely went
through an unnecessary door all right
okay now we're in the quiet safe room
where none of the people whose stuff i
stole can get to us yeah but you
literally stole a person you stole from
so where did you put that guy is he tied
up somewhere in your house what was the
point of stealing him we got a bag of
bobbish that's eight rebels first off
you literally stole items that people
from earth would recognize from a place
with nothing alien to us whatsoever how
do you suddenly have alien items sold
for alien prices secondly i'm looking at
your safe room and you have nothing
alien at all on your shelves this whole
scene seems to be setting up the plumbus
sketch for later get the orthodontist
out of here oh why
take him out of his audience kill him
sick him
demons suck his life out this is so
casually insane i've got to remove a
suit why does the doctor have a framed
picture of the anatomy of a human penis
does the image change based on whatever
he's researching or is he just obsessed
with all things i don't want to be that
girl but maybe there would be less
conflict if they didn't shoot their
shows at the same time oh summer you
have no idea how much money that must
save production would it though two
shows being shot side by side with
conflicting lighting and audio seems
like an absolute nightmare waste of
resources we get a one personal space
two personal space this guy has four
slides that simply say personal space
the other five slides at the very least
say what you're supposed to do with his
personal space which is to stay away
from it i know this might be the point
but i find it hard to believe any
dimension finds this entertaining also
this alien in the background is loving
this countdown of personal space slots
and their enthusiasm is infectious but
it took them seven slides to start
getting into it which i'm guessing is
how long it took the animators to get
into it if they measure the size of this
alien splatter on the wall then why is
there a need for judges enough to pay
for a brand new state-of-the-art
synthetic heart that will be even better
than mr smith's pathetic penis wait that
was an option the whole time yep the a
story b story i don't know what the [ __ ]
it is it's even more pointless than the
interdimensional cable shows oh wait a
second is that madea in a duck dynasty
show i can't decide if i want to remove
a sin or i'm a marine biologist who was
bitten by an octopus damn how far down
the chalkboard was this premise when you
brainstormed this episode
oh my god i'm a good person with a plan
to what exactly stick your penis in the
open cavity of a patient during surgery
how is this proving jerry is a good
person i know he's an idiot but is he
this much of an idiot this is my
butthole ice cream parlor goddamn show
so now you're resorting to humor and
semi stealing from that nathan for you
episode where he convinced an ice cream
parlor to sell a poo flavor you were
shot like 50 times 57. thankfully you're
in a super sophisticated alien hospital
so it was basically like getting a
splinter removed but replacing a
penis-like structure for shrimply
pibbles was too difficult for this
hospital you can't make people like you
you just have to wait for hating you to
bore them cinemason's long-term strategy
somehow finds its way into a rick and
morty episode i mean seriously how do
eye holes make any money and this
[ __ ] traveled from another dimension
to stop jerry from eating them penis
penis penis penis penis with your human
culture is penis
around their penises
such and such for a penis
take my penis these guys they want to
completely remove my penis this penis
will be replaced if you want to keep
your penis i prefer to keep my penis if
the universe needed his penis use your
penis you just dropped my penis on one
way i prefer my own penis this guy's
trying to get out of giving away his
penis trying to weasel out of his penis
donation and mr smith's pathetic penis
did you cut off my penis
sir i gotta tell you rick it's pretty
great to be in this spaceship just the
two of us you know mentioning a grover
washington classic and not breaking out
into song immediately after just the two
of us
we can sin it if we try just the two of
us
myself and i
i'm all alone relax that's what
windshields are for once you break
through earth's atmosphere shouldn't be
called a vacuum shield i love doing
space sins because it's the surest way
to make sure i'm wrong about something
no matter how long i research it also in
this case vacuum shields are also for
keeping breathable atmosphere inside
your vehicle in fact i'd say that's
probably enough of the primary purpose
that this plot catalyst bug protection
is nothing more than a side benefit i
didn't know that there were bugs out in
space doubling down on the space sins
would a bug in space have those kind of
wings what do they even flap against
this space bug is a lie yeah i guess i'm
out of fluid that would immediately
freeze or float away or something
unrelated to what it would be intended
for space
for millennia our society has been free
of crime and war living in perfect peace
oh i know what this is interrupting
someone in the middle of their story or
explanation one night a year where you
all run around robbing and murdering
each other without consequence thinking
legal ramifications are the only things
that fall into the category of
consequences it's like the purge morty
that that movie the purge you're gonna
have to be more specific there are five
of them now
five of them and they aren't even done
making them yet you know sometimes it's
called the cleansing or the red time so
on the planet where it's called the red
time does it happen monthly instead of
annually cause i think you may have
misunderstood hey justin i'm getting
ready to design a creature that'll only
be on the show for a few seconds what do
you think does it have two phallic
appendages on its face yep between them
does the mouth look vaguely vulvish you
know it a couple other boobs way ahead
of you hmm maybe a brown animated blob
by the butt so you can't tell if the
animal has a tail or if it's mid poop
dan you're a genius why don't you have
some candy bars as well aliens not only
speak perfect english but can also sell
earth items such as wiper fluid and
candy bars
also the candy bars have english written
on them but all the store signage is in
an alien language this planet is the
worst how can you be into this seriously
after almost two seasons of these
shenanigans how is morty surprised by
anything at this point why his reaction
what why ilching your words in space we
have something we call the
non-interference policy since [ __ ]
win
leave you alone during a purge i don't
think so baby explaining you're unable
to stop purging as you stop purging to
explain about being unable to stop
purging what part of that gives me
anything to work with my choice is to
say nothing be sarcastic or bark yes
like a trained animal you forgot the
fourth option explain the situation meta
contextually in order to launch a b plot
no one will ever remember when thinking
of this episode you know like a typical
teenager i don't want to answer any more
purge questions that's funny i heard
ethan hawk say this exact sentence at a
boyhood press conference in 2014. can
you imagine being the doofus that asked
ethan hawk a second question about the
purge when he's there for a link later
movie missing is for oblivious stevens
from how do idiots like this get into
these press events weekly you just now
remembered your nana exists rick coles
are thrifting out on her bullsh butts
still follows her into the house which
is clearly a trap to get his gun and
steal his ship even if she sucks at it
somehow little mouse on the prairie here
manages to fly a space vehicle she's
never interacted with before one that we
already know has sentience and security
measures in place heads up rapists
assuming the criminal intent of purgers
purge them me no me should i rub my
liver hole on them
[Laughter]
i only had one of those things i threw
i'm holding a box of tic tacs right now
saying this out loud wow within close
range of your adversaries
it's the space phone grandpa gave us
keeping the space phone your grandpa
gave you underneath the couch cushions
how was that helpful summer [ __ ]
summer there's a pile of silverware next
to you and you throw me the one thing
that can never kill anything he says
directly after killing something with it
morty if i can get to the top of that
lighthouse i can send the beacon and
your sister can launch our package
having a plan that involves a step of
having your sister launch your package
by the way life on other planets exists
don't let it distract you oh don't worry
no one here seems fazed by your alien
existence unless it's needed for the
plot or a joke and i don't sense either
of those things present here fade in
exterior unnamed city day reading also
forcing someone to listen to you reading
your screenplay this is not her day
fade to black
title
three weeks earlier in media's res how
are these screwdrivers attached to the
wall velcro double-sided tape does that
affect the grip and why do you even need
them accessible on your wall toolboxes
have been sufficient for hundreds of
years rick hundreds of years do you have
any thoughts notes no i i just enjoyed
it that's my note you know morty would
be terrible at cinemasins i'm not a huge
fan personally of the whole three weeks
earlier teaser thing i feel like you
know we should start our stories where
they begin morty would be excellent at
cinemasins you're a petty person and
you're insecure and you're taking it out
of me that's a good script not sure how
the writers of rick and morty hacked my
email but at least they got some benefit
from my feedback from the studios folder
whoa morty we're guests here and is this
lighthouse full of healing magic because
rick's gun wound seems to have healed
nicely he's walking around like he
hasn't been shot in the gut for at least
the last 10 minutes you like that you
want me to cut to three weeks earlier
when you were alive
this show is just the best cut to one
sin earlier when you didn't have as many
sins i remember when we used to go to
the playground and i'd push you on the
swings oh you could push me higher than
all the other kids why was he pushing
other people's kids i guess this is what
rock bottom feels like jerry being part
of a b plot so uninteresting and
pointless that the story only spent a
total of two minutes and 16 seconds on
it in the entire episode yeah i can see
what you mean how did the beacon track
rick and morty to this spot they left
the homing device at the lighthouse okay
morty now you're just shooting corpses
necro side honestly i've had my fill
it's gratuitous at this point rick
admits to fall to the show before
doubling down and partaking even further
in that fault anyway i feel like we've
seen this so much it's probably
repetitive by this point no need to sin
it again i suppose coordinated blood
dancing
feels good it's a hit song top the
charts i think explaining your
references you picked the wrong man to
push movie troutman first blood 1982. i
need food who's got food for that guy i
do but this is for me this
sociopolitical commentate's on for some
time and while i'm making food for
everyone who takes care of my kids not
being able to cook food and watch your
kids at the same time that's not a real
job trying to explain my job to anyone
in my family over 50 somehow makes its
way into this episode jerry get a job
okay fine two minutes and 44 seconds i'm
just saying if this entire b plot was
built on the taddy madison scale you'd
only owe 5.47
the trick to cereal is keeping 70
percent of it above the milk this
blanket statement presumes that all
cereal has the same absorption rate 70
may make sense for corn flakes or
cheerios but you definitely want to land
somewhere between 50 to 60 for fruit
loops or cocoa puffs and god forbid you
veer into shredded wheat territory and
end up with one of those big old ted
lasso biscuits you don't want to let
that thing soak for five days minimum
maybe in a mixture of equal parts
vinegar and dish soap after which you
toss that [ __ ] in the trash and figure
out what you're doing with your life
it's like the intergalactic version of
ups but less off-putting throwing shade
at ups and pretending like fedex and
amazon also haven't been leaving
packages at the end of my driveway and
outside of the fence our tv signals take
light years to reach this planet nobody
tell them that braveheart wins first off
a light year is a measure of distance
not time second off how about a spoiler
alert rick i'm only up to 1987 on my
academy award re-watch and i feel a
little lost because i haven't seen the
first emperor yet what the hell is a
bird person he's rick's best friend
jerry said what not who and even then
bird person is much more than just
rick's best friend he's
so
many things weddings are basically
funerals with cake cute marriage equals
death cliche but if that were true then
funerals with cake would have to
basically be weddings and speaking from
experience i can tell you they are not
you just say what's in your squanch and
people understand oh okay well
squanching squanches before casually
squanching about some squanches is
exactly the kind of squanch that makes
me both squatch and squash this show and
with all my squanch i can't squash and
squanch how i squanch about the
squatchingly squash bit of narrative
squanch am i right
maybe it's possible that rick and family
beat jerry here but i have no way to
prove it either way so i'm gonna send it
to be safe and because i'm an [ __ ]
you say you get it but i'm scared you'll
keep doing it title of my sex tape look
here's some humans you can practice on
title of the sequel to my sex tape blood
ridge on clap flaps third moon show uses
a variation of the word flap cliche
sounds like you and my dad have a long
history together this conversation gives
us insight into beth's fractured
relationship with her father as well as
her insecurities and deficits and the
interplay between all three but it also
gives us some hilariously delivered
expositional backstory about bird person
and rick the strange thing is i'm not
even mad about the exposition in fact i
welcome it what is wrong with me bird
person
you are my seed
my worm my earliness surely one cannot
be both the seed and the worm plus
lateness is generally more common when
the first two come into play pulling out
someone's innards even jokingly i am a
cyborg photographer just act natural
this is a candid shot i'm not sure if
the cyborg gaze is problematic or not
but until i can collect more data i'm
going to assume it's a precursor to
terminator salvation and i'm doing
everything i can to prevent that from
happening again
writers didn't say this joke for it's
rick sanchez in the temple of squanch
episode
also they really turn this joke on its
head being nice is something stupid
people do to hedge their bets you know
as funny as it is this is the kind of
[ __ ] that serves as a driving force
behind the show's toxic fandom and if
you're offended by that it's fair to
assume you're part of the problem now
you may be thinking that was a mean
thing to say well being nice is
something stupid people do to hedge
their bets
[Music]
bird murder
birder
the laser fire from these blasters
killed a bird person but barely leaves a
scratch on what we can assume from the
instrument and location are referred to
as baseballs squanchy is a dick to
someone's balls for no reason this
catering space fan has super convenient
worm-based countermeasures also the
smiths are super lucky the galactic
federation hasn't realized the benefits
of spaceships that don't immediately
explode when they slightly bump into
each other when they develop that
technology rick will really have to pull
some signs out of his ass [ __ ] you
summer saying [ __ ] you to your
granddaughter well at least in this case
you can't save fu to your granddaughter
we already covered this morty say you
don't watch tv sins without saying you
don't watch tv sins now who wants to go
shopping for a brand new [ __ ]
world elon musk and jeff bezos making
plans for the weekend
if the smiths think a star screaming for
42 hours is the worst of it wait till
they see its coronal mass ejections
after eating a space burrito maybe i can
buy that the space fan had a tv handy
and the rick had some sort of
interdimensional cable thumb drive with
them or something i mean i don't wanna
buy it but i'm gonna try to get past it
however i do not buy that they build a
[ __ ] log cabin in this short amount
of time also i've decided i can't get
past the working tv and cable signal
thing so
we discovered a species of tiny pig off
the coast of new australia we'd offer
you some but we hunted it to extinction
for breakfast i know the whole joke is
that living on this tiny planet is
clearly not sustainable however the idea
that not only rick the smartest man in
the universe but the entire family
excluding jerry of course wouldn't have
foreseen this food shortage as a problem
is pretty laughable especially when you
consider that later in the show rick
casually goes to a bar before turning
himself in surely they could whip up
some disguises to pick up groceries at
the nearest intergalactic grocery store
morty effortlessly sending this frisbee
around the entire planet raises multiple
questions about the gravity here and how
they're able to walk around like normal
alright just the one question i guess
morty if you go to where there's a bunch
of ice cream and then you don't come
back you haven't actually gotten ice
cream you've just gone where ice cream
is rick would be squantingly good at tv
sense where's the van morty
it's over the horizon in the driveway
i'm not gonna send rick asking morty
where the van is when he's the only
person we've seen driving it i'm not
gonna send rick asking where the van is
before checking the driveway but i am
gonna send the fact that they built a
driveway for a space fan instead of a
launching pad i'm jerry smith and i love
sucking big sweaty boners and licking
disgusting
furry testicle sacks uh
okay
only rig and morty could have stuck the
landing on the transition from that
statement to the use of non-diegetic
music to convey turmoil and the general
emotional toll of rick's life of the
galactic federation
i feel better show expects us to believe
that medicine works this quickly and as
someone who's sitting here an hour later
waiting for his edible to kick in i'm
calling bullsh and this unicorn that's
been hanging out with me for the last
hour totally agrees yeah what are you
waiting for
everything i really hate cliffhangers
like this you're gonna put a character's
fate in jeopardy at least make it
someone that we might believe will be
stuck in this prison or killed we know
rick won't be killed and we know rick
won't spend the rest of the series in
prison this cliffhanger is all kinds of
squanch
the blatant disrespect for this pizza
this might actually bother me more than
the cliffhanger nonsense why would you
do that to a piece of pizza that did
nothing to you because you're a monster
that's why
i guess you guys aren't ready for that
yet but your kids are gonna love
so what we'll do is we'll rig a bus so
that when it goes below 50 miles an hour
it blows up what the [ __ ] is that oh god
now there's three of them there too many
of them what are we going to do
how misguided are you i feed you a
couple of bullsh legal precedents and
there you go you jump on it like a [ __ ]
and eat
how's it going bill and ted
ted it's us again
so that's how it's gonna be
y'all to play
okay then i've got my eye on you jquery
that's right mrs smith give in to your
anger let the heat flow through you
they take their balls and they dip them
in cocaine i want to dip my balls in it
are you crumb opulus michael's target
very good
[Music]
you know what those guys do in in their
fancy board rooms i take quaaludes 10 to
15 times a day for my back pain adderall
to stay focused xanax should take the
edge off pot to mellow me alco came to
wake me back up again you do understand
i'm telepathic right pick a color
blue
pick a number 17. all right i'll call
the two grand i'll gamble
don't splash the pot and in my club i
will splash the pot whenever the [ __ ]
i please
what is that
that's what we're gonna find out balloon
summer balloon morty i don't like
chicken and i hate clowns
oh yeah
yeah
we are the borg
blow your shields and surrender your
ships
but uncle steve taught me how to ride a
bike steve
buttons don't work better if you hit
them harder and foam fists don't make
you strong what's my father ever done
that's so great school superintendent
big whoop there's only like 800 kids in
the entire county now i believe someone
has a final exam to attend wesley
marmalade is served
[Music]
that's rock glomer but you still can't
be in our van but by helping punky win
tv
[Applause]
shut up hamurai shut up amish cyborg
what is this 90s conan
[Music]
a giant head has entered earth's gravity
triggering climate change and natural
disasters we thought were impossible for
at least another eight years look at the
size of that boy's head time to go morty
uh where the pentagon
[Applause]
gentlemen you can fight in here this is
the war room you're gonna want to put
them on that giant speaker system at
your sonic testing facility at area 51.
i guess you'd like to see the big tamale
huh when god deals you in 11 you don't
fold and you always double down 11. and
what's your plan general we still have
the nuclear option on my word we can
launch a missile at every one of those
heads in the sky hey you better find
yourself someplace to hide and keep
praying nobody ever finds you
now you're thinking with portals
in this universe there's only one
absolute
everything
freezes
iced tea it's with these people man
lemonade read the sign lemonade the best
ice cream in the multiverse i had some
ice cream and i'm gonna eat it all
no stop don't kill him i thought about
our dilemma and i came up with a
solution that i honestly think works out
best for one of both of us that just
sounds like slavery with extra steps we
live in a society we're honor
to distinct memory
now slap on these antennae these people
need to think we're aliens right right
somebody said alien she thought they
said illegal aliens signed up nothing
you do matters your existence is a lie
you too
the incredible turbo team
i think it's okay to dream morty i'm
gonna go make some wooden stakes
[Music]
[Music]
what's that a very unpleasant little
creature what's his problem he's got a
hole
hunting a vampire with my grandkids now
this is not gonna be pretty we're
talking violence strong language adult
content
surprise motherfu
all right everybody this next one's
coming straight from the heart making
the lyrics up right off the top of my
head
let me out what you see is not the same
person as me my life's a lie
[Music]
my home planet is far away and long
since gone
please excuse his lack of decorum
his enthusiasm outweighs his discretion
that's right [ __ ] take my penis but
they'll never take
oh freedom i didn't know that there were
bugs out in space i mean bugs i hate
bugs
boy you want to give me one good reason
why you would steal snickers bar the
nougat why don't you have some candy
bars as well shut up i like candy
also if you tell your mom about this
i'll purge you are you threatening me my
bunghole will not wait i see like that
for breakfast morty but if you don't do
it i say it's because you're afraid of
your own primal instincts you eat pieces
of [ __ ] for breakfast no
i squant my family uh what i do i squank
my family frank you disgust me you
disgust everyone you know you're not
being very supportive of a bird person
on his big day how about this shut your
mouth i'll kick your teeth down your
throat and i'll shut it for you squatch
this mofo not using it right joe ah it
sounds like you and my dad have a long
history together wish i could say the
same with all due respect what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
oh that's not right
you know when i first met bird person he
was
listen i'm not the nicest guy in the
universe and for the record my name's
not ted peterson it's han solo named
after the man who made the kessel run in
less than 12 parsecs and i am a burger
like my father before me also i want to
tell everyone here that i've got a
pretty huge new kids on the block tattoo
on my back the heads are warped but you
guys it's funny
how it feels to chew 5 gum
stimulate your senses
welcome to earth